[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this guy loves aaron rodgers chris sims
who joins us on loan from nbc sports
and pro football talk live co-host on
peacock
two-man race here for mvp chris
i think so i mean you know derek henry
going into the weekend i kind of put him
on the
top three you know uh list there
but of course yesterday a little
underwhelming and yeah i ten you know me
i mean ass i'm a little biased toward
aaron rodgers we know that that's my
favorite quarterback ever i do think
he's amazing and
for what it's worth this year i really
do think right now he is the leader in
the clubhouse as the mvp will you talk
about everything he's doing the the
support system around him and everything
like that i think it's a pretty amazing
year
if i put rogers on the chiefs and
mahomes
and mahomes on the packers
how much of a change um that's a good
question
i don't know if there'd be a whole lot
changing
as far as wins and losses it might be a
little bit of a different way in which
each guy goes about it with their own
personal flair and things like that
but i still think for the most part
you'd have kansas city sitting there
with one loss and
yeah you know maybe mahomes is better
than rogers as a pure player right now
at this point of his career there's no
doubt about that i mean he's the best
quarterback in the game
so i don't know okay maybe maybe they
don't lose that tampa game or rogers
throws two picks early or something like
that
but i don't know if it'll be a whole lot
different yeah but i've got
travis kelsey who orlovsky said is
is the best non-quarterback most
valuable non-quarterback in the game
rogers doesn't have that i mean devante
is wonderful but
you put tyree kill you put that four by
100 relay team out there
and then you put hillaire they got a
good offensive line
offensive minded head coach and andy
reid um
i don't know i know i know you're
preaching the choir here you know that i
mean
this is something where i i do think
people lose sight of that fact sometimes
that
yeah mahomes as awesome as he is
yeah you could talk about travis kelsey
and
honestly he's the second thing people
worry about
when teams play kansas city the first
guy they're worried about is tyree kill
so imagine having travis kelsey as the
second option
and then when they get sami watkins back
healthy you go oh man now there's
another matchup you have
to worry about so for the greatness of
mahomes you're right
there's phenomenal talent there that
sometimes does gets lost in translation
with that whole conversation i do have
it's not a big concern but it's
something i'm just filing away kansas
city doesn't put teams away
no they do not they they're off it's on
their offense to put the teams away
right
we know their defense is not it's not
built to do that
they have one superstar player in chris
jones you know they have honey badger
who makes a few plays here and there
and frank clark and other than that it's
just a lot of good with some really
creative coaching by steve spagnolo
but it's the second week in a row right
dan where
last week they let the bucks hang around
wide open 90-yard touchdown pass to
mccole hartman
there's nine billion dollars on that
chief's offense
it's on them to put these teams away and
you saw last night with the field goals
uh and not scoring touchdowns they let
the broncos hang around and never really
delivered that final dagger until really
really late
did the jets have a good day yesterday
yes they did i mean until the last
six seconds but there was a lot to be
happy about until then i mean i don't i
don't know what else to say
that's one of the dumbest calls i've
seen in the history of football
it really is but the last six seconds
were the best part of their day
chris you're right if you ask a jets fan
it is you're right because i was sitting
here in the nbc viewing room which you
know you've sat in it before
and we got a few jet fans and they were
heartbroken that the jets were leading
late in the football game they couldn't
believe it
they were distraught and they went crazy
happy
when the touchdown happened so you know
i'm one dan i don't know how you feel
but
it seems like most jets fans are over
sam darnold
and are ready to draft trevor lawrence
and they want to start that era and
i think it might be a little bit of a
rush to judgment but um
i understand the conversation and
thought well i want to get on that
rookie contract with my quarterback
and then start to build there get a new
coach in there
new defensive court you know new
coaching staff all of that
and then see what i have now i was told
yesterday
don't be surprised if the jets would
hold on to sam darnold one more
year if they do take trevor lawrence
wow i don't know about that i don't know
how that would help them i would think
that would just
lessen his value for a trade or anything
like that
plus you don't want trevor lawrence
coming in and having to deal with some
of the
faction of the locker room that are sam
darnold supporters or anything that
wouldn't be a recipe for success
i would think they could get a second
rounder for sam darnold
you know at some point in the off season
the tough thing about sam darnold is we
don't know
exactly what he is yet you know every
time he starts to play he gets hurt or
he gets mono
or then he gets hurt again so we've
never seen extended consistent
good play from him i know the jets a lot
of people there in that organization
really think highly of them um but i
think my dan to your point
this is going to be who's going to start
this trend
who is it going to be who's going to be
the first team that finally says
you know we have a good team and even
though we win
in our quarterback he's not the
franchise we're good no matter what
and we're not going to pay him 38
million dollars and ruin our team who is
going to be the first team to do that
that's
really what i can't wait for i was also
wondering about this when i saw what the
jets did
and i went back to the previous drive so
the jets give up the game winner
double move there's no help over the top
they go all out blitzing
you know vegas was fourth and three in
the red zone with
145 to go or something like that they're
down four
williams called a blitz again brought
seven defenders
and derek carr panicked and you know had
an incompletion threw it off his back
foot
they had to know they kept darren waller
in on the final drive the final play two
block your best receiver
is being kept into block so they knew
what was happening
they knew williams was going to send the
blitz i was just
i didn't understand an undrafted rookie
on rugs
and with no help and then biting on a
double move like that
now that i don't understand what role
does the coaching staff play
in telling these grown men hey whatever
you do don't let somebody get behind you
well it it doesn't matter because you
know there's so many things to break
down there
you know first off yeah you talk about
the pressure in the series before on the
fourth down and he you know throws the
incomplete
pass hey it's it's a different ball game
right to blitz down there you got the
end zone
behind you you don't have to worry about
deep passes things like that
to do that where they did there's so
many things
first off john gruden probably has
better understanding of greg williams
defense than
any other defensive coordinator in
football my six years with john gruden
man when we played greg williams he used
to call plays every now and then and i'd
be like
man is he expecting a blitz here he's
crazy if he thinks they're going to
bliss i'd get up underneath the center
and be like
man johnny gurdon is right they're going
to blitz holy cow i can't believe this
i was shocked by it so he has great feel
there's a little personal rivalry there
and you're right obviously he knew that
and the poor undrafted corner for the
jets what is he supposed to do yeah you
want to tell him
don't bite on any double moves but if he
lets if henry rux catches the slam
he's not going to be fast enough to
catch him there and make the tackle
either so
he's really was put in a no-win
situation and
uh there's just no other way to say it
other than that was just a horrible call
or i don't know greg williams was
deliberately trying to stick it to adam
gase in the jets and wanted to blow the
game i don't know
are the browns a good team or a very
good team
oh i'm still going to go with good team
but the last two weeks make i'm starting
to think
maybe they are a very good team they
have two elite things about their
football team in my opinion dan
the first thing is their run game you
know that the offensive line is special
they have the best o-line and online
coach in football and bill callahan
and then that two-headed monster running
back and then the other great advantage
i look at them always is
they have a front four that can get to
the quarterback without blitzing or
doing anything like that and that's
going to help them play off football
when you can run the ball
and pressure the quarterback and baker
mayfield
playing with some confidence and not
turning the ball over and doing that
they're on the verge i think of being
very good but i'm still going to go with
good for right now and you bring up a
couple of really good points when it
comes to post-season football
do you travel your running game travels
you've got a good offensive line you've
got a defensive front that can put some
pressure on the quarterback
it's going to come down to baker
mayfield not getting squirrely
i mean it really is going to come down
to that i mean that's
stefanski's done a wonderful job as a
rookie head coach but
you know i'm with you the rams good or
very good
oh i'm still gonna say good too uh
i think the the one part of their team
that you know i still question
a little bit and jared goff was really
good yesterday but when they play
really good defenses and they can't run
the ball can their drop back pass game
win them football games i think that's
still a question mark for me
but they're on that same thing there
just on the cusp of being very good i
mean
a little inconsistent but that's the
interesting thing about the nfc right
now the nfc
just it it seems like it's so up for
grabs
and uh has a chance i think to be a
really exciting playoff run because the
teams are so close and so equal
i'm going to make you doug peterson for
a week your starting quarterback against
the saints is
oh i think i think i would probably go
to jalen hurts finally
i would do it for two reasons one carson
wentz is a beaten puppy i mean he's just
it's everything's his fault even when
it's not his fault we all blame him
so i think he's kind of like deer in the
headlights right now the team needs a
little
new energy new lift and i think at the
very least okay if he does well
you go hey look he did well this is
great but if he fails
you can then maybe quiet some of the
critics too and then go look see he
wasn't quite ready yet let's just give
them time we'll still play with them and
use them in certain situations
but i think if i'm philly right now i
probably do make that move
yeah i do too um and i wonder the value
of carson wentz in the offseason
i i it's a valid question i think
there's no way they can get rid of him
because of the salary cap situation it's
such a big dead cat
money and i think they're still if doug
peterson's there there's still enough
believers i think that coaching staff's
realistic enough to know
hey the kids got talent we haven't done
the best job with them and then of
course howie roseman and
some of the busts on the offensive side
of the ball with draft picks and things
like that it's not exactly talent around
him either
so i think they're going to give him one
more shot almost no matter what happens
the rest of this year yeah we were
wondering about the value of carson
wentz and
and i said value maybe for the colts and
frank wright can reunite
those two after philadelphia i don't
know what to say good
thought but sam darnold's value on the
open market
i don't know what kind of value that
would be
like i don't know what the patriots are
going to do i don't know what san
francisco is going to do
with atlanta's detroit lions yeah yeah i
don't i know
i don't i don't know that i did want to
bring this up before we go
bill belichick what he did on the road
against the chargers
i mean 45 to nothing and cam throws for
less than 100 yards
i don't know what belichick is doing you
watch the all 22 so you see whatever
there's no greater game plan adjusting
coach in
in the history of sports in my opinion
than belichick
from series you know quarter to quarter
game to game
he somehow does something with an
offense that's you know
his makeshift yeah but was that
impressive what they did against the
chargers
definitely very impressive now the
chargers you know with their special
teams issues always
find ways to make teams look better
right but
that's the new england is playing almost
perfect football
in all three phases of the game for
about five six weeks straight now
and that's because of the head coach
that's where dan you and i had the
conversation
kobe 19 for get the damn talent on the
team or anything the fact that belichick
couldn't be there coaching them and
on them with all the details and all
that that was the biggest issue they had
during cobia 19.
but the big thing about them cam manages
the game the right way
the offensive line is one of the best in
football as far as running
is concerned and they run the proper
plays into the right look
every time and then you know their
defense and everything there that
chargers team
it's a top 10 defense a top 10 offense
to get blown out like that's pretty
embarrassing and i would think anthony
lynn's a little in trouble there
but would you rather face the bills of
the patriots in the postseason
oh
that i mean i i would probably
the bills are playing better you got me
stumbling all over myself here
i'd probably want to see the bills i
probably would you're right the patriots
come into town with that run game
running the clock
that's secondary and the things they can
do there to shut down just about any
passing unit in football i think would
be very scary
uh that's a close one but i think
because of the patriots mystique i'd
probably rather see the bills than the
patriots
thank you chris as always we appreciate
you getting up with us
you the man i've been up for a while and
tell all those
good guys they said hello good guys yeah
these guys say stuff behind your back
though chris all right i take it back
tell those jerks i said
okay that's better that's better thank
you that's chris sims on loan from
peacock pro football talk
co-host and of course football night in
america